Okay, let's look at the solution for our
data dependencies quiz. We have these four instructions.
And for each type of dependence, we need
to figure whether these pairs of instructions have these
dependencies. Let's start I1 to I3. We already
know that there is no read off the
write dependence. That is because I3 doesn't use
the R1 value produced by the I1. Right after
read, would mean that I3's writing a result into a
register that was supposed to be read by I1 which is not
true. Write after write would mean that I3 is overwriting
the result by I1 and that is true. Now let's go from I1
to I4. I1 is producing R1. I4 is reading
R1, but the value that I4 is supposed to read here,
is not the one produced by I1. It is the value produced by I3.
So in fact, there is no raw dependence from I1 to I4.
That would occur only if I4 was reading R1 that was produced
by I1, which is not happening. Is there a right
after independence? Is I4 over-writing R4 that was supposed to be
read by I1? No, because I1 is not reading R4. Finally, is there a write
after write dependence? No, for two reasons. One is that I4 is writing
to a different register than I1, so there cannot be an output dependence.
Another reason is that even if I4 was writing
to R1 that would be an output dependence between
I3 and I4. So there would be an output dependence from I1 to I3 and then from I3
to I4, but because the right is happening to
R4 and here to R1, certainly there is no
write after write dependence. Finally, let us look at
I2 to I3. Is there a read after write dependence?
Is I2 producing a register that is read by I3? No, it is not. Write
after read would mean that I3 is overwriting a register that I2 needed to read,
and that is true, because I2 needs to read R1 before I3 overwrites it.
So we have a write after read dependence. And finally, we do not have a write
after write because there are different registers for
writing. So this is, again, not selected. So
the only check marks you were supposed to put in are this one and this one.